today for our daily cancellation i will
be canceling women uh
not all women don't worry in fact if you
are a woman i hope that you do not fall
into the category being canceled this
afternoon i am canceling
women who have a tendency to claim that
relatively normal yet uncomfortable or
irritating social interactions are
sexist
now i suppose i could simplify by saying
i'm canceling feminists but i think that
there may be some women who don't
identify as feminists and yet still fall
into this trap
so now look i'm not talking here about
things words behaviors
that are actually abusive or degrading
to women in fact just this week
we've discussed the latest cardi b song
which is intensely degrading and
dehumanizing to women
yes it was a woman who produced it but
even so it amounts to an attack on the
dignity of women
and there's plenty of this sort of thing
in the culture and if you're a woman who
has spoken out about that
god bless you to you i say girl power i
will i will join you at the protest
march for that
that's not what i'm talking about what
i'm referring to here are as i said
the more ordinary everyday social
interaction-based
sexism claims if you want examples of
this kind of thing just go to google and
type in
sexist microaggressions or everyday
sexism or similar keywords
you'll be greeted with volumes and
volumes just like this one random
example from yahoo finance finance
um this is just you know one one article
a pop tab of many
and the headline why sexist
microaggressions are holding women back
at work
so just reading a little bit of this it
says around 64 percent of women are
supposed to uh
exposed to this kind of discrimination
according to the report with black and
lesbian women facing an even greater
variety of microaggressions in the
workplace
uh and then it con continues so what are
examples of microaggressions experienced
by women
that's a very good question according to
the women in the workplace report the
most common issue is women having to
provide more evidence of their
competence than men and they are more
likely to have their judgment questioned
even on things that they're an expert in
um
and then the article goes into you know
anecdotes from various women
here's one it says one asian woman who
had worked four years at a company told
the report
authors of her experience of a
microaggression she said i was in an
elevator to
press the button for the executive
office someone said to me um no honey
that's for the executive offices
the interns are going to this floor
that's not funny but i
another middle eastern woman the vice
president of company added
i walked into a meeting where i was the
only woman in a very large room of men
and when i sat down an older white man
from another company turned to me
out of nowhere and said could you take
notes for the meeting
which was a little bit odd because i was
the lawyer
in the room uh the one doing the
negotiating
okay so those and then it goes into
other anecdotes and so on and so forth
um and then it it stipulates importantly
microaggressions can be hard to pinpoint
they might be brief comments or small
actions such as interrupting or talking
over someone in a meeting
no matter what form they come in
microaggressions can have a serious
impact and create a toxic working
environment that might seem innocuous
but over time these incidents and
comments can lead to self-esteem
or rather to low self-esteem feelings of
alienation and impact
on mental health all right so a few
classic examples there of alleged
micro sexism uh that you find
there are other classics that you've no
doubt heard being told the smile is one
women will sometimes complain that
others remark on their lack of smiling
and uh and they'll chalk that up to
sexism
of course there's the old favorite
mansplaining and mansplaining is any
time a man explains something in a
condescending or patronizing way i'm
doing
man's planning right now in fact
unwelcome advice
a cousin of mansplaining is another
example so questioning of judgment
interrupting talking over talking to
telling a woman to smile explaining
things doling out advice unwelcome
touching unwelcome flirting
all of these are commonly considered
sexism and they're used to promote this
this this narrative of a
of a patriarchal and male privileged
society
but it's all bogus
almost entirely bogus might there be
some occasions where a man
interrupts or explains or says you
should smile more because he has a low
opinion of women
sure i suppose so i can't see inside
anybody's mind i don't know
what i do know is this that all of these
things all that i just listed
all of these supposed sexist anti-woman
aggressions however micro they may be
happen to men all the time all the
time none of this is unique to women nor
is there any credible reason to assume
that they ex that they're experienced
more often by women
all we know and save yourself the
trouble of sending me links to studies
look at the studies the studies say the
studies have declared
all we know is that women more often
report and remember these incidents and
interpret them as sexism
what we do not know is that women
actually experience
these events more often and i submit
that there's no good reason to assume
they do
now this is all anecdotal of course but
that you know all of this is the claims
from feminists are anecdotal it's all
anecdotal so let me add my own anecdote
okay
i am told to smile all the time
i have just never cared enough to make
note of it or
or of any specific incident and to store
it away in my head as a traumatic sex
experience
sex is experience because ultimately i
don't care what other people think of my
demeanor or my personality
a lot of people hate me and hate my
demeanor and personality fine
doesn't matter to me your opinion of me
is irrelevant
i don't care what about being talked
over what about being interrupted
condescended to
men experience that all the time all of
that
though men who who learn to assert
themselves will experience it less but
that's true for women too the point is
that
if you have a more submissive
personality
you're more likely to be ignored or
overridden especially in a work
environment
in a competitive environment that's not
an anti-woman thing that's a that's a
human society thing like it or not
what about unwelcome advice are you
kidding me i would wager here that 95
of all the unwelcome advice given in a
day across the world
cumulatively is supplied by women
now this is partly a positive reflection
of women though women give advice
nag we used to call it for the same
reason that they gossip it's it's the
downside of the more positive attributes
more common in women
of sensitivity and empathy women are
more likely to care what other people
are doing thinking saying and feeling
yes this can lead them to gossip it can
lead them to nag but can also lead them
to be wonderfully caring and invested in
other people
and you know and very empathetic now men
we're less likely to care all that much
about what other people do
the plus side is that we don't nag very
often we're less prone to gossip
but the negative side is that we can
sometimes lack sensitivity we can lack
empathy we can perhaps
err on the side of indifference more
often than we should
um this is a difference between the
sexes and one of the reasons why our
differences are complementary and one of
the reasons why it's so great to have a
mom and dad in the home to balance each
other out you need sort of both
sides of this but the point here is that
is is simply that
because of the masculine and feminine
tendencies just described
some of this everyday sexism is far more
likely to
come from women so
why does it seem like women experience
these things more how could it be
possible that
somehow men have been become known in
modern society as the nagging busybodies
while women are suddenly the aggrieved
and frustrated victims of this behavior
it's it's it's absurd well i think it
has a lot to do with
another difference between men and women
men only articulate about 10
of their emotions and experience for
women the number is closer to 225
these are not scientific figures i admit
but the point is that
uh men don't talk as much about what
they're feeling and going through
and are especially unlikely to go home
and tell their wives elaborate stories
about
you know being interrupted at a meeting
or being told to smile and how
how upset it made them not because it
doesn't happen but because for one thing
a man might feel embarrassed that he was
emasculated and therefore
be more likely if anything to tell a
story about some other incident in the
day
when he was assertive and in control
just to assuage his bruised ego
also he won't bring it up because men
are more practical
even about emotional matters and
admittedly to a fault sometimes so a man
will
calculate in his mind whether the story
about his day is actually useful or
relevant to anyone
and if he decides that it isn't he won't
say it
women don't perform those calculations
as often
for better or worse
now that's where the confusion comes
from
it is like so much of the confusion
between the sexes a matter of
miscommunication or lack of
communication
and now i'm starting to sound like my
wife who for the record has never in her
life
said the phrase microaggression or even
sexism unironically i don't think i've
ever heard her call anything sexist ever
which is awesome and so this time she is
not
the one being canceled but a bunch of
other women are i'm afraid
being cancelled which i'm sure they will
hasten to say
is sexist on my part so be it
the cancellation stance hey you uh
yeah you you're right you right there
hit the subscribe button right now
do it do it right now i thank you for
your compliance
it's somewhat appreciated